let's talk about venezuela and why it
has two competing presidents
juan guaydo is the one recognized by
dozens of countries
but nicolas maduro is the one in charge
in parliament the opposition parties
hold a majority but elections are coming
up
and the opposition is split over whether
to boycott them
while the politicians argue people in
venezuela are struggling more than ever
you can see how desperate the situation
is here
so if things are so bad why does maduro
still hold power
what could happen if the opposition
decides to sit out the elections
and why aren't there big protests
anymore
[Music]
for years we've been watching venezuela
climb to the top of
just about every awful index there is
[Music]
worst economy in the world the highest
murder rate
and a refugee crisis that rivals the one
in syria
more than 5 million of its 29 million
strong population have fled the country
that's down to a combination of bad
economic policy
corruption and in the last two years
sanctions
and this is how hard it is for people to
feed themselves
hyperinflation has made venezuela's
currency the bolivar
almost worthless the minimum wage is 1.2
million bolivares a month
that's just over a dollar at that rate
you'd have to work
two months to buy a carton of eggs and
prices go up
every week it's a mess but it wasn't
always this bad
venezuela was once the place to be in
latin america
caracas the swinging city of venezuela
its
huge oil reserves helped build a booming
economy
but over time corruption and inequality
grew
and the shine started to wear off
[Applause]
enter president hugo chavez
[Applause]
[Music]
his social programs were popular but
they relied on taking over
businesses controlling the currency and
high oil prices
which eventually crashed so by the time
chavez died
his vice president nicolas maduro
inherited an economy in a lot of trouble
then 2018 happened maduro said he won
the presidential race
but the opposition and a lot of
countries disagreed
there was no international observation
the main opposition coalition was
actually barred
from presenting candidates under its
unified ticket
so the opposition basically said the
presidency is vacant and according to
the constitution
the president of the parliament should
take over and call new elections
that man was juan guidon
the maduro government felt like they
were being usurped and
actually it's ironic because juan gaidou
has referred to nicolas maduro as a
usurper but
the other side feels the same way so for
the last two years
both men have laid claim to the
presidency most opposition parties
consider guido to be the acting
president
he's also recognized by nearly 60
countries including most of latin
america the us
and the eu and then there's maduro who
has the backing of countries like russia
and china
and he's the real authority on the
ground
he has the loyalty of the military the
national guard and a civilian militia
military officials also control
industries like the state oil company
and maduro's appointees run institutions
like the supreme court
and even though the government is nearly
bankrupt venezuela still manages to
trade with allies like turkey and iran
just can't access those kinds of
resources but he does have public
support
just not as much as before in 2019
hundreds of thousands of people rallied
for months back in guido
[Applause]
the bulk of the opposition strategy
hinged on getting the military to break
away from
maludo something that never happened
and after nearly 50 people were killed
mostly by security forces
momentum fizzled out
[Music]
guado's coalition of opposition parties
then tried other ways to put
pressure on maduro and they had help
from abroad
sanctions have blocked venezuelan oil
exports government assets worth billions
of dollars have been frozen
including venezuelan gold in the bank of
england
mercenaries have even tried and failed
to overthrow maduro but after
all that maduro is still around and his
supporters say
what the opposition has been doing is
evidence of an international conspiracy
to remove maduro
and here's another thing maduro is
pretty unpopular
his disapproval rating according to one
pollster is 77 percent
but gwydos isn't far behind many feel
that
maybe this hard-line stance of juan
guido has not worked
these sanctions that were supposed to
drive maduro
out of the flores palace have not worked
and now there are parliamentary
elections maduro says more than 100
parties have candidates running
and he's invited foreign observers but
guido and some of the main opposition
parties
say the elections have been rigged from
the start opposition leaders have been
jailed or simply removed
and several political parties have been
banned they also say the body that runs
elections
is made up of people appointed by the
pro-maduro supreme court
so instead guido and the main opposition
parties are doing their own thing
they're calling on people to boycott the
election in december
and in the meantime they're holding
their own referendum it's to ask people
if they approve of what maduro's doing
and if they want him gone
[Applause]
but some just aren't convinced they say
it's better to run and try to win a seat
in parliament
either way maduro stands to win control
of basically everything
and people who want change haven't been
protesting the way they used to
they're in the middle of a pandemic
there's a state of emergency
there's also a lot of fear
human rights groups say that an
increasing number of journalists doctors
opposition politicians
and ordinary citizens are being detained
so the protests
may be smaller but the anger is growing
[Applause]
kovit 19 may generate fear among people
but surviving every day is the main
worry for many
people who four or five years ago were
able to sustain themselves and
and able to get by and reduce to just
unthinkable poverty
a lot of people also seem to have just
given up
many have lost faith in politicians
protests and elections
whether juan cuado can convince people
to boycott the vote and take part in his
referendum
may give us an idea of just how much
hope is actually left
while you're here make sure to subscribe
like or follow al jazeera wherever
you're watching this video to stay on
top of world news
and i'll see you next week